In straight turning, the tool is fed parallel to the axis of the work...
...to reduce its diameter so that the final diameter is the same at each end.
Removing a significant amount of material in one pass is called rough turning.
The final lighter cut that creates a smooth surface finish...
...is called finish turning.
Taper turning produces a taper along the axis of the workpiece.
Tapers are produced by offsetting the tailstock from center line...
...or by using a taper attachment.
Short, steep tapers can be turned using a compound rest.
Contour turning or profiling was formally performed...
...by having the single point cutting tool...
...trace a template of the desired profile shape.
This has largely been replaced by CNC turning,...
...in which the desired contour is simply programmed into the machine,...
...which directs a cutting tool to cut the contour.